foreign
[Music]
large-scale training and inference on GQ
and I'm Alex zachanov I'm a director of
engineering for Google kubernetes engine
team
and with me is Nathan who works on a
product site and we'll be talking both
overview of why you run large-scale
training coincidence
as well is a concrete new developments
that we providing in the product to
enable this functionality first
mentioned gke is a key part of Google AI
ml infrastructure stack
and that reflected in growth that we see
in the space and in our customer
experience so just over the last
12 months we saw over 200 percent growth
in workload running inference and
workloads running training on gke so
which is a tremendous growth and that
grows on like really big base it's all
kind of fun can I share the exact base
but
industry breaking type of growth
and if we look on the usage usage come
in from all segments from Oggy customers
from small to the largest ones
but the key thing that we see pretty
much all our largest customers
using gke for large model training
and as well as a running large model
inference
so what's unique challenges that we are
experiencing the industry
we see tremendous growth in the model
sizes
graph represents growth
gpt3 this Jeep T4 Visa Palm this llama
models and that growth doesn't stop
why that growth happening because as we
increase the model size
we see
fundamental shifts in the model
capabilities
so we're going to be on the trend for a
while like what exactly will happen
where exactly the trend will stop and
we'll go to a more plateau
still to be seen But at current moment
winds that rapid growth phase
and
each next layer unlocks your business
possibilities for our customers
and why our customers use gkey like
what's behind that
first and most important as we're going
through that fast scaling phase
you need to have a platform that both
can scale dynamically with you to really
high limits but also do it in a cost
efficient way
because
for the large models training extremely
expensive influences also extremely
expensive so unless you have a solid
platform that provides all the
foundation for performance and price
performance
it can be really dangerous from a
healthy business standpoint
so second
key thing is we're in a rapidly changing
Market
so in a rapidly changing Market your
time to Market time to value for your
customers is super critical so one of
the most important things is how fast
you can bring new capabilities to your
customers and how fast you can validate
those new capabilities
so
this G key we provide a standard
platform that spans across all your
application types that spans across your
traditional web apps stateful apps batch
applications
and
now bringing EML training and inference
of topology key what it means they can
reuse all the best practices you use all
the policies that you have within the
organization for what it takes to
prepare application for production so
let's see your one standard platform
that provides fast time to Market with a
for Enterprise radio applications
the last key point is EA email is still
extremely new space
and what it means that we'll see
significant term in Tooling in ecosystem
in the next couple years like you see
new Frameworks new offerings new OSS
tools coming up almost weekly
and
jiki is based on kubernetes kubernetes
is a open and standard platform
and what we are doing we are making sure
that in that highly and fast evolvement
space we provide the open foundation
for you that you are not locked in in a
specific tooling
so how that translates to concrete and
Investments that we do in uh on gke team
to support you
and I'll start from the bottom of the
diagram
first is G key foundational EML platform
so in the foundation one of the key
things that we see is for large models
high-speed networking
is one of the key things to enable
large-scale training so we invest a lot
in integration with gcp networking both
on a GPU site on a TPU site
to unlock training scenarios second both
for training and inference storage
performance is super critical
pretty much as we think about for
inference latency load time for the
models is a or one of the key
characteristics so we partner very
closely with gcp storage teams
to enable differentiated storage
performance as part of gke clusters so
that's a foundation
and in that Foundation we ensure that we
have we cover all platform compute
platform options across TPU that was
announced yesterday
GPU and CPU
so you get consistency of compute as you
rely on gke
as we look on specialization between
training and insurance workloads the key
envious means in training is on
hyperscale clusters
GTE today provides larger scale
kubernetes clusters so we support a
single cluster up to 15 000 nodes
and we support multi-classer
architecture with gkey Enterprise
so training is really pushing the
boundaries of training both within
single region multi-region
enabling
the skills that you need on incidents
the balance is different on inference
the key things is latency of your
inference models
price performance
because especially for the large models
serving is super super expensive
and so is a high throughout put for
models that are successful for your
business
so there's three key areas of
Investments that you will see happening
in gkey as we
integrate trade Insurance offerings in
the G key
the last Point going to the top of the
diagram is ecosystem as I mentioned eaml
and GNA is a highly highly Dynamic space
and in that highly Dynamic environment
variety of tools that we'll all be using
is gigantic yeah and the key Investments
that we're doing on a gke both provide
out of the box integration for all
popular OSS Frameworks
and we also partnered with early
startups early with a stream works that
still on the rise
providing open platform for that with
that I will pass to Nason to cover in
details Investments that we do in both
on a training inference and ecosystem
site
[Applause]
thanks Alex
so I'll start by discussing how gke
enables large scale training
and to structure our discussion together
we can think of a typical architectural
cake diagram
a successful ml training experience
depends upon amazing foundational
infrastructure
kubernetes then provides the critical
orchestration layer
and above that an open source kubernetes
native system called Q provides many of
the features you need to manage jobs
and on top of gke you are running your
ml Frameworks tools and libraries
I will start at the bottom of the sack
and work upwards so first gke provides
diverse and industry-leading accelerated
compute options
now most managed kubernetes offerings
support gpus
but today I am thrilled that we have
announced that gke is the first managed
kubernetes offering to support tensor
processing units
Google's custom designed machine
learning accelerators are now generally
available in gke
we've brought together the remarkable
price performance offered by tpus with
the industry-leading scalability the gke
provides
customers like character AI light tricks
weights and biases and grammarly are
already experiencing some of the
benefits
of tpus in gke
if you're already using Cloud tpus gke
can save you money and simplify your
operations by scaling up when demand
Rises and scaling down when demand Falls
light tricks an AI first company that
develops photo and video editing apps
for creators found that TPU support ngke
has replaced many of their custom
scripts that they built to operate their
large model trainings
weights and biases which provides a
developer first ml Ops platform has
worked with Google to add support for
cloud tpus to their launch product
and their TPU support is built on gke
in grammarly's research on large
language model alignment
grammarly found that Google Cloud
tpus and Jacks outperformed many similar
offerings that they evaluated along
dimensions of performance reliability
and scale
and in his keynote yesterday
Thomas introduced the cloud TPU v5e our
most efficient
versatile and scalable AI accelerator
and today I am thrilled to announce that
the TPU v5e is available as a preview in
gke
v5e offers up to 2x more performance per
dollar for training workloads compared
to our previous generation of tpus
v5e is designed to offer highly flexible
VM shapes to perfectly fit your diverse
workloads
and our multi-slice technology
enables v5e to power massive ml
workloads that scale to tens of
thousands of nodes
I'm thrilled as well that in the coming
weeks the a3vm powered by the Nvidia
h100 GPU will be generally available in
gke
training very large ml models requires
tremendous Network throughput between
nodes so we designed the A3 to have an
order of magnitude more Network
bandwidth compared to the previous
generation
with eight h100 gpus in a single VM
the A3 provides remarkable 26 exoflops
of AI performance shrinking the time it
takes to train models
the A3 is revolutionary and customers
like tab 9 depend upon it to power their
business
tab 9 offers an AI powered code
completion trained on permissive open
source repositories
to compete tab 9 depends upon the speed
and price performance of A3 VMS running
in gke
the power and scalability of the A3 in
gke allows tab 9 to rapidly build
train
and serve each of their customers in a
way that's personalized to their private
code
I've spoken several times about the
diverse options gke provides for
Accelerated compute
our A2 Mega VM is unique among all
hyperscale public clouds
it's the only VM offering 16
a100 gpus on a single VM
with 16 a100 gpus on a single VM many
customers find the A2 Mega's unique
shape can offer Superior price
performance for training large workloads
AI 21 Labs is one of the leaders in
developing Foundation models
they have found that the A2 Mega helps
them cost efficiently run their products
and r d workloads because of the A2
omega's unique configuration of 16 a100
gpus
Salesforce AI research found that A2
Mega makes it easier to fine-tune large
models and saves time during model
training
we've seen the gke's diverse
flexible and Powerful accelerated
compute options our one key way gke
enables you to train massive ml models
another essential aspect of training
large models is getting fast access to
lots of data
and that's why I am thrilled that today
Google Cloud Storage fuse is generally
available on gke
fuse is short for file system in user
space and it allows application
developers to use common file i o
operations to access GCS rather than
using GCS specific apis
if your workloads fetch unstructured
data
now you can move those workloads to gke
without requiring any change to how you
access files
standard python file semantics work out
of the box to fetch data from Google
Cloud Storage making your applications
more portable than ever before
GCS views can also speed up the time of
your application
by allowing it to load data and start
processing that data before all data has
finished loading
customers like openx are already using
GCS fuse with gke and have found it
vastly simplified configuration of their
applications and accelerated pod startup
Time by up to 40 percent
on top of a diverse powerful and easy to
use foundational platform
gke adds the very best of our managed
kubernetes offering
gke supports the training of massive ml
models by scaling to as many as 15 000
kubernetes nodes in a single cluster
outscaling other public clouds by up to
3x
because the scale of ml models is
increasing far faster than the size of
Hardware accelerators a multi-node
training architecture that supports
massive scale is critically important
and gke uniquely offers that
as the number of nodes in your training
cluster increases the probability that
any one of them will fail naturally
increases as well
since one node failing means all nodes
must wait we've made extensive
Investments to help you maximize
workload uptime
gke's proactive notifications give you
advanced warning about potential
breaking changes in future kubernetes
releases and our maintenance Windows
give you control over when upgrades
happen
if any unplanned node failures occur gke
can detect and auto repair the node
while allowing training to resume
quickly
when training ml models you need the
entire job to get done with all pods
working together as a unit
and with many different teams sharing a
access to limited compute resources
so to make this easier we've invested in
q
an open source kubernetes native job
queuing system
if you have many teams within your
organization all sharing limited compute
resources
Q makes it easy to share those resources
together
with Q each team can get their fair
share of resources
while bursting to take advantage of
unused resources elsewhere
with Q the most important jobs get
priority
and lower priority jobs get preempted
and all of this is fully open source and
integrated with a diverse ecosystem of
ml tools Frameworks and libraries
we know gke is just one piece of your
overall AI Journey
so that's why we support a diverse
ecosystem of tools Frameworks and
libraries
so we've seen gke provides pay-as-you-go
access
to a world-class supercomputer whenever
you need it for training ml workloads
let's see how gke enables high
throughput low latency serving
so just like training I'm going to start
by looking at the foundational
infrastructure that gke provides and
we'll work up the stack
a few months ago we announced the
general availability of the G2 VM
powered by Nvidia L4 gpus
G2 is the industry's first Cloud VM
powered by the Nvidia L4 GPU and its
purpose built for AI inference workloads
with up to 4X better performance than
the T4
by switching from the Nvidia A10
GPU to G2 instances organizations can
lower their production infrastructure
costs by up to 40 percent
unlike the a 10g or the T4 The L4 GPU
includes FPA support which can drive
even better price performance for
serving workloads
I spoke earlier about how easy it is to
chain together many TPU
v5e chips into a massively scaled
supercomputer for training workloads
the v5e has very flexible VM shapes
making it Stellar for inference as well
with up to 2.5 x more performance per
dollar for inference workloads and up to
1.7 x lower latency for serving llms
compared to the prior generation
v5e can provide an affordable
low latency serving for your ml models
on top of our inference optimized
Hardware
gke adds amazing kubernetes goodness to
make serving models fast
reliable and affordable
traditional kubernetes offerings even
many managed kubernetes offerings still
require that you manage your kubernetes
nodes
to help you focus more on your business
and less on infrastructure management we
built gke autopilot
autopilot is a mode of operation in
which Google manages your cluster
configuration including your nodes
autopilot is perfect for ML serving
workloads
allowing you to build and deploy faster
without the need for deep kubernetes
expertise
the resources requested by your
kubernetes pods are backed by Google
sres
reducing the burden of day two
operations
we found customers love autopilot for ML
serving workloads
so I've talked about how gke is an ideal
home for your large-scale training and
serving workloads
but as workloads scale costs tend to
grow as well
so I want to spend a final few minutes
discussing a ton of ways that gke helps
you optimize your spend while
maintaining your customer experience
one of the best ways I've seen customers
save money doing inference is to remove
from their container image any unused
Nvidia libraries
and to serve using Nvidia Triton and
faster Transformer
one customer that I spoke with was able
to achieve a 75 reduction in the size of
their containers by doing this
I've seen other customers move inference
workloads from a single a100 GPU
to a multi-host inference architecture
in which the model is split across many
smaller gpus such as t4s
and in exchange for slightly increasing
your serving latency this can lower your
GPU costs by up to 50 percent
and gke auto scaling and node Auto
provisioning makes it very easy to serve
primarily using spot gpus which are up
to 90 percent cheaper but to fall back
to on-demand instances when spot becomes
unavailable
whenever you're serving user-facing
traffic you'll generally want to
provision slightly more gpus than
immediately necessary in order to absorb
a sudden spike in demand
if it takes your pods a while to get
scheduled on new gpus
then you'll need a large GPU buffer
which raises costs
so we've invested extensively to ensure
that new gpus can spin up quickly and
your workloads can get started right
away
gke image streaming provides you with up
to 3x faster application startup by
allowing your workloads to initialize
without waiting for the entire container
to download
and as I mentioned earlier GCS fuse
we've seen customers using GCS fuse on
gke reduced by 40 percent their workload
startup time for data intensive
workloads
many organizations also share
infrastructure across numerous teams gke
provides built-in metrics
dashboards and alerts to measure and
attribute per tenant costs as well as
powerful tools to increase your compute
utilization for each team within your
organization
one of the ways that you can save money
is by using many containers on a single
GPU to then increase your GPU
utilization
and gke's GPU time sharing allows
multiple containers to share a single
physical GPU allowing you to more
efficiently use gpus
this can be perfect for bursty workloads
like notebooks or low volume inference
gke's multi-instance GPU support allows
you to partition a single larger GPU
into several smaller ones
perfectly fitting each of your ml
workloads
and in the coming weeks gke will support
Nvidia multi-process service which
provides an additional way to let
applications share a GPU concurrently
helping you to increase the utilization
of your gpus and lower costs
we've seen how gke is a stellar platform
for your AI workloads enabling
cost-effective training and serving and
that's certainly true
but what makes gke even more powerful is
that it can do this not just for your AI
workloads but for all your containerized
workloads
customers like light tricks rely on
gke's diverse Hardware accelerator
support by mixing and matching tpus and
gpus
and lightrix uses tpus for efficiently
processing text prompts and batches
using a large text encoder and then
employing gpus to run an in-house
diffusion model
there's no other orchestration platform
that offers such a diverse mix a tpus
and gpus
customers like lightrix and Salesforce
grammarly and AI 21 labs
tab 9 and openx and so many others
depend upon gke as part of their AI
Journey
and I am excited to see all the ways gke
can partner with you in the coming
months to play an essential role in
accelerating your organization's AI
Journey